hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
bacterial classification by shape
basically there are several different
shapes that bacterial cells can take
these include a caucus shape the plural
of that is oxide these are spherical
bacteria
an example of a caucus type bacteria
would be Staphylococcus aureus
there's also bacillus these are
rod-shaped bacteria the plural of this
is the cell line and they have these
longer rod shaped structures an example
of a bacillus type bacterium is bacillus
anthracis which causes anthrax next
there are spur Ilham shaped bacteria or
spur illah these are sort of spiral
shaped an example of perilla bacteria is
Treponema pallidum which causes syphilis
there are also curved bacteria sometimes
you'll also hear them referred to as
comma-shaped bacteria so as you can
guess curved bacteria they're sort of
curved they look a little bit like a
comma an example of a curved bacterium
would be Vibrio cholerae which causes
cholera then there are some bacteria
that they have a shape that is somewhat
it's queen cox i and bacilli so there's
sort of spherical and sort of broad
shape they look something like this
now these top three are the most common
types of bacteria but of course you do
see these shapes represented as well now
in addition to bacterial shape there are
ways to classify bacteria based on their
organization into groups so basically
how the different [ __ ] size cells are
the different bacilli cells how they
actually clump together in groups over
here we're just going to use this top
one the coxide bacteria as an example
but these are types of organizations
that can be used by various other types
of bacteria as well so for example with
diplococcus think diplo here diplo means
two so these are when the two [ __ ] I
are in pairs so basically they clump
together in pairs and this would be one
way to recognize the diplococcus type
species under a microscope while you
look for two spherical cells that are
joined together
Staphylococcus like Staphylococcus
aureus staff elope refers to grape like
clusters so these are when the caucus
cells are sort of in these clusters like
this
and they can be identified under the
microscope that way
streptococcus has this root strep toe it
means in Chains
so streptococcus bacteria like
streptococcus pyogenes that causes
scarlet fever
it grows in long chains
now you might ask why is this important
well it's important to know what
bacteria look like and how they're
organized into groups so that doctors or
nurses nurses or researchers when
they're looking at a bacterial specimen
under the microscope they can determine
what type of bacteria is this is
important because if it's a bacteria
that's causing an infection by
identifying what kind of bacteria it is
that helps doctors know how to treat the
infection of course bacteria shape and
organization and groups usually isn't
enough often you need these two pieces
of information as well as a differential
stain information this means staining
the bacterial cells on the microscope
slide with something like the Gram stain
or the acid-fast stain to get more
information about what kind of bacteria
is causing the infection if you'd like
more information about the Gram stain
technique or the acid-fast stain
technique you can see my separate videos
that go into more detail on those
procedures so that's it for today and
thank you for watching biology professor